[Music]
you
what's up everyone how's it going it's
thirst
there's Thursday it's Thursday Thursday
I love Thursdays and we're here playing
the new Red Dead Redemption to update
they brought battle royale yeah to this
game swert we're gonna check it out
we're actually positioned in a really
good spot where the modes actually just
about to start so I'm gonna switch the
game over and we are going to you check
it out the the actual mode itself is
called gun rush so if you want to queue
up for it's that's what you got to look
for mm-hmm I think it's got you said
it's got its own hopper so you can
actually pick it out right yeah it's in
the Quick Menu there's also gun rush
teams so we'll take a look at that so
far look those eyebrows ends but the
most donk eyebrows Melissa I love them
so far I mean you know it's in beta
mm-hmm still beta so far I have been in
you know there's a 32 max player count
I've been in teams of five tops but
we'll see if you know this just came out
maybe people are still filing in could
be it here's a vehicle we've got our
first vehicle procured so there's
there's no dropping out of a plane
there's no no crazy beginning to this
you just kind of spawn at different
parts of the map and then it actually
starts doing the better way out thing
where you go around find weapons and
ammo and the play area starts shrinking
it's a shame they didn't incorporate
that hot hot air balloon right that
we've been yeah oh but I don't know if
parachutes were invented back then so it
would be an interesting thing to see
either way now this mic stands kind of
covering my map yes it's a heck of a
thing oh there are more people who are
coming in and inspecting so you might
actually have a fuller game coming up
yeah so that's kind of thing is like you
know the matchmaking as far as getting
in and like that is that is a core
feature necessary for battle royale
right is is getting right back into a
game so it it kind of seems like it's
there but because there is I don't know
I it it feels like that they're not
waiting
very long in the lobby like they just
want you get back into a game hence why
there's only five people or so like I
just feel like there's are not enough
players oh go hello I punched you though
where'd you get your hat sorry for
yelling oh okay he came out of nowhere
that was the first first one of the day
right first first battle royale a day
apologies for the peeking there I'm
thinking I just screamed into people's
ears what platform are we on we're
playing right now on the PlayStation 4
home entertainment console Pro placing
playstation pro yes specifically but
along with this update that came out
today that brought us better royale they
also kind of outlined what their plans
are coming up for the entire read it
online they're saying that they're gonna
be in beta still for a couple of months
but they're working on a lot of really
cool stuff which has me actually kind of
excited yeah I want to hear more about
that um George do you want to jump into
it like right now sure yeah all right
this is spectating and as well let's do
it
tell me about what's coming up we've got
this wonderful post here on GameSpot
calm by Chris Pereira detailing out what
they were there they've got going on so
so we've got new race modes new showdown
modes new clothing and emotes which is
kind of like the surface layer stuff
we're kind of like okay cool you're
expanding on what's already in there
right and because of all the feedback
we've been getting during this beta
they've kind of got like a road map
detailed for what they're gonna be doing
so the first major thing is daily
challenges so they're going to be doing
things from sharpshooting to evading
like law law dudes that's what I call
police officers I guess chair marshals
so you're gonna be able to get XP boosts
and money through that probably and most
of the major adjustments that they're
detailing are kind of ways to mitigate
the unpleasant interactions you have
other players I literally took Chris
Breyers words word for word yeah so
they're changing the law and bounty
systems to reduce the
the kind of want people wanting to go in
like grief other players there they're
making that so it's not not as good to
kind of make it some people who want to
do it yeah so there's going to be if you
actually go and murder someone it's it's
actually like a legitimate crime you'll
get a bounty and you'll actually get
bounty hunters chasing you around across
all the state and so basically for
should either pay your bounty off or
you'll get killed or you'll have to
escape
so it just messes with them whenever
they're trying to do something cool
which is very good that's cool
and they're also changing the way the
map works this is the thing I'm very
excited oh and resting okay so the map
will actually show players at a much
shorter distance so you can't like see
people all the way across the map and go
and like track them down to mess with
whatever they're doing that will be very
good and there's also gonna be a way to
more clearly identify people who are
aggressive so maybe it'll be kind of
like that if they've been killing like
five people in a row everyone will see
them wherever they are so they know to
avoid them so this is exactly what you
were kind of hoping for a while ago you
mentioned this where it's like if you're
if you play good you won't be seen on
the map if you play bad you're killing
other players then the whole map can see
you yeah it's kinda what they're hinting
at which is I think yeah that's that
sounds really good solution it sounds
like they're like actually listening to
yeah two people who are playing the beta
which is really rad yeah and apparently
they're also adding a new story arc
coming up really soon with more story
characters that you know from the
campaign more dynamic events or just
dynamic events in general so they're
gonna have like it sounds like maybe
destiny style like you go up and you do
like a mission where so a trains being
robbed and you can either join in or
help or something maybe something like
that so that'll be cool yeah I'm really
excited to see where this is when they
decide to take it out of beta cuz it
sounds like they're actually moving and
putting a lot of stuff in because I've
we've both been kind of not not really
feeling the online beta the way that
it's been totally like I I think you
know once
once you do the yellow story missions
and the beta you fall off real quick
it's just this what's left you know like
it's just like stranger missions which
are very repetitive and I don't know yes
it's not fun going to Bonnie McFarlane
for the third time and have her being
like hey glad to see your back you
should go and get this right a
stagecoach for me again like Bonnie this
is the third time I've done this why are
you why are you losing your stagecoaches
again yeah god this match is really
riveting yeah these people are taking
the signing I mean like I'm I okay so
they know where each other are like she
clearly knows that he's up there he he
was looking at her I think this guy
hasn't even moved
there's my dead body right there he's
[ __ ] pen oh yeah crime carvings up a
good a good point we have a Resident
Evil 2 demo livestream coming up later
on today
oh they're creepin yeah we all knew it
the only was gonna happen
yeah later on today John Doak and I will
be playing the Resident Evil 2
one shot demo Resident Evil 2 at 2 p.m.
Pacific with two people two attempts to
real it's gonna be a good time so make
sure you you stick stick around for that
possibly definitely if you're feeling it
alright it's me I like Alan and this
battle royale mode they they show you in
the end how many deaths you had one it
was only one which is good so I did okay
that's not a bad like amount of XP and
money comparatively to what you'd get
and like regular PvP but now I've got
seven people here we go see that was
time to fill up it's kind of worth
hanging around there yeah I mean no
streaking so there is a shrinking circle
but I think they were just really lucky
and it was shrinking onto them
yeah you kratz the camper one that's how
it goes sometimes I guess unfortunately
oh we're doing it at the Manor so that's
the other thing I was mentioning too I
like how they're doing other parts of
the map now for the different
multiplayer modes yeah do you know how
many there were previous it felt like
whenever I played it was on like maybe
like like maybe three or four different
like actual spots on the map right but
like one was strawberry one was like
these landing
you'd have black water for the the
bigger modes I think like land grab and
all that I don't even do that one I
think that was my favorite one just cuz
it was it's fighting in like a kind of
urban environment there's a lot of
verticality cuz you can climb up on top
of all the buildings but I'm glad to see
more more areas come in okay eyebrows
yeah let's do this let's do this who
finds the most Easter eggs and res evil
2 wins well we'll see what we can find
apparently you can finish the demo in
less time than they give you so we'll
poke around we'll see what's going on
it'll probably be like an hour long
because we've got two two copies of the
demo downloaded good
okay this will be interesting cuz you've
got all these like fields that kind of
lay low in if you need to yeah like do I
even bother with a horse I feel like
maybe to grab a gun really quick it
that's that's how Battle Royale goes you
know yeah do you risk it to get all the
weapons or do you lay back and play it
cool oh hello you shot his hat off Oh
whew it's a head shot
it was very good I worked out oh yeah if
you guys have this downloaded there's
probably a good chance that you'll get
put into our game if you want to try to
play with us yeah if there aren't that
many people playing and we don't have a
full game yet I don't even know where to
go I feel like last oh [ __ ]
go with a shotgun I just had flicked up
I was a semi-auto shotgun - if he missed
that first shot he would could have been
Anya all these people are in the house
it's a nice jacket I can't wait anymore
I don't want to do this
Hey just rotate it around keep it going
I mean this is how you play a bat
already I get right back into it yeah
it's a better work mm-hmm get that will
we ever find Gavin who knows where's
Gavin has anyone seen Gavin Gavin oh
there we see this is it people are
getting on people are waking up people
are waking up we've got some sweet music
playing all right cool this one starts
up pretty quick this is good yeah all
right this this is this is what we're
looking for a crime says they missed you
rob ah thanks crime crime kremser crumbs
a good a good person it's good to be
back
Yeah right a new year I was there it
only got through like half of our break
before I was like me I can't watch house
back yeah yeah it's just it's I feel
like I'm not doing anything I thought I
could be doing things yeah and also it's
nice that you know things were really
kicking off like in previous years
you know January February March even are
fairly slow but they're kicking it up
real fast paced combat around the corner
you got anthem Metro resident evil'
every yeah it wasn't evil for sure
February 15th is a big day yeah yeah I'm
not gonna bother with a horse anymore
just a target on a horse battle Royales
taking over the world yeah I feel like
we're getting the point though where it
might be like I don't know I feel like
everyone's tried their hand at it and I
don't know if it's gonna like I feel
like it's gonna try to stop stop going
where everywhere like there's only so
much bad oil you can do I guess I don't
know yeah I don't feel like there's as
much buzz around it anymore either I
feel like it's on the downward trend
yeah there we go that's what I was
looking for that's a guy that's it's
like it's it's wearing thin like people
are still people are still trying to
like it's a it's like at this point it's
like whoever is pitching or full games
on senator on battle royale they're kind
of late to the party right latest noise
I've ever made it's it's scary battle
royale games are the most intense horror
games you know he's got two guns you
know the vegetation there is is it's
very hard to see people it's true though
Kanto says more like a new yarn oh I got
him 2019 is a year a runescape do we got
to prune scape guides no Rove is that
what's happening far cry new dawn is
another one yeah I don't know how
excited I am for that dope I'll play it
yeah it's it's far cry it's got good
shooting in it and it seems like it's
kind of cool yeah that's fair I was very
excited for for DOA I'm very excited for
I'm actually more excited for anthem
than I thought I'd be I'm excited for
Anthony the more the more I see of it
the more I'm like yeah yeah flippy robot
so I like it this is good this guy's got
a heck of a beard started for residents
you obviously excited for Devil May Cry
and March that's gonna be very good
y'all this royale goob how you doing no
this is a dust storm I've never seen a
dust storm of hers is the other day I
haven't seen it I oh oh oh oh oh did a
dive Oh the dive the dive is very I got
it's like the role in GTA yeah I forgot
about that
I keep doing that Jonas says looks cool
is it fun it imagine playing Red Dead
with the battery it's I don't know it's
it's hard it's hard to have an opinion
at the moment maybe by the end of the
stream I can so stick around assess my
feelings but this isn't this isn't what
I want from read that online you know
like this is not what I'm looking for I
I don't think I ever woke up at any
point in my time playing Red Dead 2 in
the morning and one man I wish that
online had a tryout I just want I just
want it kind of like the original one
where there were kind of things that you
could do around the world and I could
play some some verses type of stuff yeah
I'm really sad and I hope that they
eventually bring this back but my
favorite thing about doing competitive
in the original game was those stand
offs and I want those stand offs back
yeah duels yeah like starting off a team
deathmatch where everyone's just lined
up staring at each other it was really
cool cool
eight people hanging out in this one
more people some said keep late duo's
you can play team so probably yes to
hose
I wonder what what how many people
what's like Ghent like I think generally
you do like in Red Dead online as it
stands you can do you can do teams right
but up - why is it four or five he's
four or five yeah we we had a full full
posse when we were doing the launch day
of it and like one of us couldn't join I
still I still feel kind of bad about
that
that first day you and you and Mike were
just hanging out and I finally got in
and I feel like he made a rude gesture
at me so I beat him up you know run all
the way back I don't know it's you gotta
you gotta bottle up your feelings about
red dye and frustrations at least that's
fair because I have gone very fresh I
guess yeah I don't know it's just it's a
cruel world out there I feel like the
way that it launched it has all the
necessary tools for griefing but not for
actually playing the game yeah which may
be a bit of a detriment cuz like oh cool
we finally got the lasso in there's
nothing to do in the open world but run
up to people and lasso them and track
them along yeah which is very fun it's
very fun if you're then as long as
you're the one last wing someone it's
very true yeah now I remember that I
lasted you and tied you to a horse at
one point I remember I like had read it
online running and like went to the
bathroom came back and everyone's like
huddled on my TV laughing I'm like what
and it's just me being dragged others
got here
great I'll be honest about the aiming -
I kind of like when you could just shoot
the gun in the old game this one you've
got to kind of paste your shots out
which is it's cool its tactical it's
methodical but I don't know if it's for
me I'm like doing your warming up this
is this is bad away I'll see the madding
paid Story DLC I don't know maybe for
like side characters like I'd love a DLC
or you could play a Sadie that'd be
really cool and I'm gonna bet we'll get
something kind of like undead nightmare
so I feel like that did very very well
plus the aim-assist ruin it a bit I feel
like you need the aim assist I mean it's
it's not like I don't think people who
use free aim are any better than anyone
else or anything but it's weird
it's the the fact that you have to like
stop and paste your shots out and I like
how in the old game you could just kind
of like get your cursor on someone and
pull the trigger a bunch
and it's not Turco bingo its trickle
bond wait what is my name circle bingo
I don't ask why I hate my name I just
want this ps4 name change to happen
doesn't say because my god name change
I'd like to wipe my past apparently if
you still change your name there's a
high chance that you might lose like
some of your DLC or something what yeah
which is we're very apprehensive it's
such a mess I don't know how that works
but I'm excited for it either way cuz
I'm I want to change my name really
badly mm-hmm gosh I almost I almost like
would take that risk of losing DLC in a
way yeah I don't know if that's just
like them be like oh it's coming and
this is the problem we're having and
they're gonna work it out or it's just
like it's like yeah sure I'd love to
lose the license to my stuff that I paid
money for that's not a scary prospect at
all with all of our digital stuff that
we've got going on they didn't make
Story DLC for their biggest game GTA
they won't make it for Red Dead
Redemption I made it for the original
one which is my only thing that makes
you think they might undead nightmare is
a very very good example of what they
could do rip your old trophies yeah do
you know is that go is that for sure
gonna be a factor is it I don't think it
is I think that's why it's not happening
yet is because they they want to try to
figure that out as best they can what
will be your new name oh this is this is
where you get to have your name stolen
by everyone and I'm oh yeah I can say
that see that caught it stops you dead
your tracks gonna be Butthead 4/20
nailed it I read online as limits that
sorry you'll see they're already
planning on putting a new chapter in
sometime soon you know I thought about
how I don't like the aiming sort of but
when you do get the shot off like that
that's really nice
I'm looking at my map I feel like too
much maybe I don't know I'm still
learning
I mean maybe the way that I would do it
I think at least with my knowledge that
I have now is sums like you're shooting
I look at the mini-map otherwise I'd be
I'd be scanning these tree lines cuz you
know there's someone somewhere yeah also
I can't wait til you add like custom
games to this I want to get like a 32
person just like hand hand fight going
[ __ ] like surreal like a real mosh pit
situation I think that'd be pretty fun
cuz the hand hand and this is actually
really really good yeah be cool slappers
only yes laughter is only that's what
we'll call it the official game spot
slappers only playlist setting okay you
put hit record on that oh yeah oh wow
how does this so hot I'll just have to
do it later see right here oh it's at
the top yeah no well it's very confusing
there's like no the buns are kind of
weird in there anyways oh my god Oh see
like how do you do that how do you tell
your person to not just do one hit in
that situation now yeah it's like
everything's so freaking slow I hate
everything
get me out of here that's fine that's
cool do it again
that's cool
what if Arthur Morgan becomes a fighter
and smash celebrate the bread that
online getting out of beta that's a
that's a heck of a it's a heck of an
idea I don't think it would happen but
at this point all bets are off
anything's possible in smash asking you
look at the map you can but like that's
the thing is it's so slow to pull that
up yeah
compared to other games I feel like I
don't know you know it's really weird is
you're hanging out here with all your
friends are on the fire you're having a
wonderful time telling stories but you
all secretly hate each other yeah and
then all of a sudden you all just decide
well let's just go to Strawberry and
shoot each other like oh that guy that
guy spent microtransaction money on his
his gloves they're the fingerless ones
of course they they lock the fingerless
ones behind the paywall pack to smash we
haven't played smash in the office in a
while yeah I want to I played smash
pretty much all break same said I ended
up I end up finishing adventure a
hundred percent of dit and I started a
second playthrough oh wow I played a
bunch with my my family which was nice
but uh yeah we need to get it back going
in the the office today's payday that
could be a would be a cool thing
yeah definitely might be slow but can
you show us yeah you can pull it up
maybe at the beginning just to kind of
like oh the map sure I can show you the
map yeah I mean I definitely had like
urges to pull it up but at some point
it's like
I get yeah so there's the circle and
there's where it's gonna close into all
the weapons are definitely more in the
center which is kind of weird yeah and
like the circle is always gonna close on
the same map or Manor or town or
whatever it is right yeah it doesn't
seem like it's very random it's not yeah
it's not moving around who's excited for
resin evil - we are so excited in fact
that we're doing a live stream of the
demo today at 2:00 p.m. Pacific
so if you want to watch us fumble around
and I think it's actually just the e3
demo so kind of stuff that's already
already out there a bit but well we'll
do two playthroughs hang out be John
Luke and I having a good old time trying
to survive and not be scared we'll
probably get really scared heck yeah and
you got a travel award question is who
sees me now do another smash battle
arena yeah I didn't even see it but the
speed zone had it's a live stream on
Friday before everyone went on break
where everyone just hung out and played
smash s okay to the left yeah he's out
in the field over here right to the left
yeah
at least that's where I saw the smoke
pop up yeah he didn't hit you too hard
so that's good
[Music]
x-games is spectating
let me see that ugly mother yours show
yourself
is really into hiding
serpentine there you go there you go
there you go yeah that's the move that's
what we're looking for is this the only
online mode for the game so no there's
still the the open world stuff that's
there there's a little bit of a
storyline you can play through the more
of its gonna be added later and there's
a couple of like vs. team deathmatch
they've also got like territories that
kind of thing
well think so you pick up besides guns
are there health or anything we thought
that there might be armor but that might
just be a helmet that guy was wearing
but we haven't run into anything yet oh
my god
hello he's trying to pick out a book and
you just murdered him I hate I can't see
it's so hard it's so hard to get any
kind of angle on anything that plants
scared me I was going on what's new in
the update so it's it's basically just
this since I think some balanced things
but they did detail out like a roadmap
for what they're gonna be doing down the
road because that's what you do with the
roadmap I realized I repeated myself in
a way that's kind of silly you went
upstairs went upstairs
God move you jackass
No aah
oh look at that smile he's got ah that's
that's that's a second-place finish
that's the second place finish Rob
that's that's good ah ha ha you're gonna
get so much experience so much money
haha what death stop that it's not bad
at all I just felt like I was feel like
my player was just resisting the
controls are so finicky in this I'm just
not very good that's all it is no the
trolls are real rough doodle yeah
classic doodle so it's not a beta it's
not out of beta yet one of the things
that we said was it's gonna be in beta
for a few more months but we're gonna be
having stuff pop up they're gonna do
more regular updates yeah switch to
first-person in doors
that's an interesting yeah it's kind of
how you do it in single-player right for
like for like scavenging and looting
listen a bad idea
it feels so awkward that's a good idea
let's try that I like that cool thanks
for the tip it's good did you have you
changed your you're running control so
you don't have to tap to run I don't
really you just hold it uh you don't
even have to hold it you just kind of
like engage it doesn't press it once and
he'll start jogging it makes it much
easier to kind of move around quicker
huh also means you can sort of jog and
still aim which I find is really useful
okay I'll do that that sounds cool yeah
it's kind of weird at first but it makes
a lot of sense after you mess around
with it Rob's hot right now he's feeling
it it's warming up it's getting it going
my best run yet I feel like this
game-mode is just a concept cuz they
they had the original kind of outline
for battle royale where they spawned you
in and you had like just knifes and
the map closed in knife servos so I feel
like they're changing it and adapting it
but it's I mean it's more battle royale
though than it was before I'll change
the controls after this Oh a sandstorm
and so on looks really cool is this just
for online I don't think I've seen one
in single player apparently there is in
single player it's just out in the you
know Blackwater new Austin area
so haven't spent enough ah good a
hunting knife this is perfect so I
wonder how well you could do in this
game mode if you just kind of run around
and tried to melee people cuz that one
game mode that gets you different points
depending on how difficult the weapon is
to kill people with I would literally
just run around and stab people to death
and it would work out really well
because no one could can hit you fast
enough yeah I mean I could see that
especially with like just like the delay
in response with controls I don't know
yeah I mean if someone came by me with a
knife I'd probably freak out how do you
like to stab me just do it it's also
really nice because you can like you
just run full speed at someone and then
press circle and you tackle them and
then you just stab them on the ground
like there's it's not very technical I
think there's a bit of a little bit of
button mashing you have to do but most
people aren't prepared for that can you
jump in a car in this mode you can jump
in a horse there's there's horses just
get around the map
that shot was very close
[ __ ] this is going that's gonna the
rights going real well yeah that's all
that guys are right yeah Oh
Deadpool every time oh yeah
settings controls I think it's down
further yeah running mode so instead of
hold chocol yeah cool that that works
pretty pretty well it's weird because
like GTA and I think we're dead before
actually changed it by that to default
for multiplayer yeah but they didn't
want to do it for this one how cool
would a DeLorean Easter Egg be though
pretty cool I'd be into it as the update
for both consoles yeah it should be
available on on both I'd assume yeah if
you haven't played read it online give
it a go it's it's battle royale with
cool hats cool has indeed a.m. so there
are only two people left so that's not
too bad you know see this through most
of been playing against the same people
we've actually kind of jumped from game
to game and I guess it's been kind of
hit or miss this was one time we had
like what 14 people in a game and then
we were starting off and we just had
like like four or five so I'm wondering
if it's just people kind of not being
around to play or people just kind of
waking up or downloading the update yeah
yeah black ops we're still looking at
Battle Royale
I actually still think it's my favorite
Battle Royale I like blackout a lot it
might be because it's the one that I'm
best at - oh it's Buckethead oh here he
is
yeah I'm here ready to play
got him shoot him Oh oh no he got too
scared he jumped outside of the whole
thing Oh what are you doing bugging that
he's taking the scenic route I guess he
was right there cuz he didn't see him
mm-hmm he's on a horse right down here I
was hoping I could get him coming in I
think there's room enough for different
battle Royales but like we said earlier
I feel like I feel like it's it's
starting to kind of died out a bit
people like for tonight people like pub
people like black out heck people will
probably really like this one ah there's
their shots happening did he get him I
don't know it's acting really buggy
babies being betas thought Buckethead
playing a guitar he's mixing it up he's
diversifying you know there you go
you got a nice Kratz all right he's an
army of one everyone should have known
going into this that it wasn't gonna
stack in their favor
Oh like a scar that's really cool yeah
he's got a cool scar what's popke it's
the way that I say what everyone else
does Pub G because I like to be
different
popke get it in get it in get it in get
it in you so so you know there's the
Dead Eye perks in this online that are
different from the single-player there's
correct me if I'm wrong there's one Dead
Eye that allows you to like regain
health I think there's a card for for
something like that where when you're in
debt I you start healing right away or
something so shouldn't you put that on
right yeah that would make sense
someone mentioned my dead I was low but
like I I want to say that they
intentionally make it low in this mode
because when I was in free realm it
wasn't that low and I don't think
there's anything in game like I don't
know if you can equipped let me see yes
I think it shows up from shooting people
oh right that's one way yeah okay maybe
can you eat snacks okay because you have
anything inventory right I was well as
gonna check and see if I had anything at
all yeah
because obviously not weapons let's see
I also hope that Rockstar make some
single player DLC Michael like you even
if it is just the one off like you're
crazy one like we did for the original
game but I hope there's something there
no I can't even I can't even pull out my
satchel but you don't even have a
satchel you just have an empty holster
but Eldridge in oh oh see that they
force you into certain debt I owe ya I
would have been able to select my other
Deadeye cards in single player or a pre
rum it's fair
an even playing field Oh
loading on this is ridiculous
yeah seems like it's kind of kind of
slowish our player blips disabled in
gold rush I think they are disabled but
they might pop up when people shoot kind
of like when you have a bit of a heads
up I'm very excited for those changes to
how for your roms gonna work like that
that might actually make me give it a go
again how do you guys feel about the
controls I feel like they could be
better
like I love Red Dead Redemption to a lot
but it's got it's got some issues and
the controls are the really big one I
wish Rockstar would kind of just over a
halt how they lay their controllers
control stuff out for the game overall
but yeah Oh store DLC about Landon
Ricketts would be good I still I still
say that my my like top idea for for a
DLC story thing would be for Sadie I
want I want more Sadie like all the time
yeah she's awesome
spicy says I'm watching y'all in school
loved the gameplay I'm glad you're
having a good time spicy I like your
name
you hope that yes they did a new update
where they added a new more battle
royale mode than they had previously and
then they also gave us an update on what
they're gonna be doing down the road for
the game and kind of where it is in its
beta status so it's all all good we're
gonna be seeing some new content coming
up it's giving me some hope for this
because be honest I kind of kind of
wrote it off a little bit
I was like man I'll just stick to
single-player stuff I guess but I have
hope now that's good shame is on PC yet
would be good to play there yeah I think
that the PC version if there ever were
one would probably probably help a lot
of the control issues because you could
rebind all the keys also shooting with a
keyboard and mouse probably very good
the looks cool and fun can't believe
people are complaining about a free mode
that's true and they do go out of their
way to make sure you know that it's a
beta I'm not not like angry at it or
anything I just I'm excited to see where
it goes from here it's kind of a cool
thing the restaurant with your friends
in right now but looking forward to that
that more substance you know oh yeah
sure show dirty socks who's the boss
it's a good name I like it he's not
gonna be changing his name someone's got
stinky feet aim assist yeah I don't
think he'll think I'd ever do free aim
I'm not I'm not that hardcore I tried to
set it up in single-player and it didn't
work out for me I'm gonna be gonna be a
misis scrub till the day I die
world feels so empty so that's one of
the things they're also trying to
address they're gonna put like like
random missions out in the world and
stuff there's a hole right up we have on
gamespot about what they're gonna be
changing in their their roadmap that
they detailed so you check that out and
see see what's going on with it oh man
but more content and the changes to how
the map works in the open world have me
probably the most excited yikes yikes
Rob you got it get him what is he like
riding out what was he doing I looked
away for a second I he I just I saw him
dart I mean it like this this is a good
area where you don't want to sprint as
much I think you just wanna I killed all
those people like every single one every
single one yeah
killing it perfect I really like the
thumbs up your carry character is very
own brand got night $19 30 39 cents 400
XP that's lunch that's lunch man ship it
if only has some more kills I didn't see
anyone for a while if only you saw is
that dirty socks with the the top hat no
shirt really it's gotta be dirty socks
oh man come on scream lobbies I could
see the appeal of it and I'm sure that
later on once more stuff kind of gets
situated they'll probably have free
lobbies to force it yeah
he did win rob1 he did it he took the
whole thing didn't didn't feel great but
well that's kind of the nature about a
Royale sometimes right yeah I mean it's
unless you have like the the full number
of people in there like theirs right I
feel like there's something kind of not
there I still got really worked up when
I did the the knife battle royale one
look I got like that weird like exciting
feeling in your chest when you feel like
you're about to die oh yeah classic
Battle Royale
it's a good feeling it's real good
feeling reminds me I'm alive yeah that's
good it's a good way to have a heart
attack
um I was I going to say oh that's the
mode that was initially in beta right it
was the I guess you could call it it was
more just last-man-standing right with
uh with like just throwing knives or
whatever his throwing knives are bows
the one that I got was throwing knives
that gameplay is up on our gameplay
channel if you want to see me totally
choked at the end and not get first
place that happened to me with the Call
of Duty Battle Royale where they call
that again
blackout yeah I got a second it was so
intense I was killing I had like I think
I had like six kills I was feeling so
good and then just choked it oh that was
that was the one where we were all yeah
part of it it was a morning meeting and
like there were about a dozen people
watching me play and I just like I don't
know it's one of those things we were
like I should have just rushed him I
don't know there's so many different
ways you could have done it and you did
those all kind of filter through your
head yeah but after I did I try to I try
to throw a grenade and he came out and
I'm just killing me and I'm out in the
open this is not a good idea it's
alright yeah you got a knife though
right you yeah run off on a guy with a
knife get it yeah hi I'm here alright
what are your opinion on gold bars in
the beta microtransactions are bad I
shouldn't have to I like that you can
earn them but I feel like you should be
able to earn them faster because it's
weird that I have to buy like a duster
coat with real money yeah like I think I
think it's a little egregious to split
the currency like you you you know you
initially want to compare it to GTA
online and and in GTA online you at
least weren't reminded constantly yeah
that there is a currency that you could
pay that you can pay money and to get
these things faster because it's all
it's all one currency it's just like a
dollar in the game right here it's just
like as you just mentioned like when you
start like separating items with with
that gold currency it's just frustrating
because you can't you can't look at that
golden currency no go I'm gonna get
there someday like that it you get such
a small amount I mean granted you know
this is a beta so they could adjust that
it's just the economy once we did it
once yeah I feel like maybe not
everything that is priced with gold bars
should be priced with gold bars I feel
like like individual clothing pieces
should be good for money and you should
be able to buy that with things that you
do cuz that's all like there but what
what gold should be there for oh my god
it's the same guy wait there are two
people there excuse me that's not that's
not bucket boy it was bucket boy and you
seemed a Nazi that and the crazy Mountie
or did you shoot his helmet off maybe it
is huh but I think that gold should be
reserved for like I want to buy John
Marsten's outfit or I want to buy
Arthur's hat or like things that you
don't necessarily need but you can be
like oh that guy he must have been
working really hard to see out enough
gold to buy Arthur's hat or or something
like that
or they just bought it with money but I
feel like it it shouldn't be for like ah
the Duster coat or the fingerless gloves
or the gambling hat or whatever a random
thing they're like ah we've got all the
not cool things not for gold but all the
cool things you've got to pay gold for
that's yeah especially when it's like
some of the you know like the shotgun
jacket or the stalker hat yeah I think
one of those is like fairly expensive
and online and those are some of the
most popular items in the single player
you know mm-hmm it's just I don't know
it's how dirty would it be if they
actually used like single player
purchase data to like decide what they
wanted to monetize like Oh everyone's
got the shotgun jacket that's gotta be
five gold bars exactly but yeah I feel
like maybe that kind of like specialized
stuff would be better for for
microtransactions
a twenty two people
heck yeah we're all we're almost up
there look at all these wonderful people
hanging around this fire the dreaded to
online get any other big updates or just
this one mode I think it's just this one
mode and some balance things but the the
big thing for me is the the roadmap for
what they're going to be doing coming up
did they say when that I don't think we
have any dates on anything it's just
kind of like in the coming months will
be coming out of beta and we'll have a
whole bunch more stuff you're ready for
it Red Dead online for real yep and
check out that stories like crisper air
on gamespot.com
see what's going on with it but also if
you're enjoying yourself hanging out
with us today right now while we're
playing this this brand new battle
royale mode you should subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss a single
stream that we do stream every weekday
at 11 a.m. Pacific all sorts of things
Red Dead game modes previews we'll be
doing a demo playthrough for Resident
Evil 2 a couple hours
it's a good time and we hope that you
hang out with us and stick around
because I want to be all of your friends
and we can hang out because we're doing
read our Resident Evil later on a day
that means that John Luke and I tomorrow
are probably playing Halo again like did
you know he's gained it chase him chase
him a tackle him Peter John Robb beat
him down yeah yeah tip circle tap circle
to it no oh no oh he's got a gun though
yeah yeah heck yeah sure want to go get
your gun gonna go get got more like damn
like a seat that was kind of fun see
that in battle royale adopted that was
really good anyway yeah so just playing
Halo tomorrow where is his gun so if you
want to join you had a gun I can't get
your gun Oh God
I'm so I'm so f it's Robyn beat him down
- oh god did you see me no oh man
pretend I'm a bush just space banana man
wasn't having any of it oh boy now it's
kind of fun
Scott he's got some good hair stuff
going so we'll try to run me over in a
horse but yeah so halo Master Chief
collection Xbox one tomorrow come hang
out we've got a game spot group on Xbox
that will kind of funnel you all into
and see if we can get get all the people
playing again Rob you're you're down to
hang out and play some halo if you're
not doing anything shell yeah heck yeah
hell yeah
Rob will probably be there you can you
can try to shoot at Rob but he'll
probably get you anyway because it's
good at halo
yeah he was a very good time I'm glad
that we're able to get that many people
and I hope we're able to do it again yes
hey I feel like at that point like I
well how come I couldn't pick up his gun
I don't know I have no idea
that's not how it should work that's not
how it should work I had nothing there
was nothing near me like I don't know I
could have gotten a hope man I got ships
connell horses booked it but you're such
an easy shot you know you're elevated
like oh the click was in our game I'm
gonna game shoot no we didn't see you if
we definitely didn't make it far you
take your hat your hats gone oh yeah
cuz your eyebrows very clearly oh yeah
my brother my eyebrows are my hat
because they're so thick they're real
just I keep thinking of the word donk
the dark i wraps
oh man Oh Arthur Morgan's in the chat
how you doing
I keep forgetting about oh no what you
caught the dive the divers dive is
clutch am I using as much as I should be
dude you're halfway to level 10 for
stamina sprint so much hell yeah
gotta pay gold bars to pick up guns
like MasterChef I like MasterChef -
would you ever oh there's would you ever
really need to use this bow and arrow
like at any point I picked it up god
damn it I think the only benefit to it
is is on silent yeah I haven't used it
enough to know how like viable it is
because I rely on repeaters too much
good how are both of us we're doing
great Arthur playing playing some new
battle royale mode you know speaking of
Arthur Morgan uh dirty Artie tomorrow
yeah I'm gonna see here and distract Rob
as much while he's a candle he's trying
to like make this work yeah there's
gonna be a new dirty arty episode coming
up tomorrow you ready for that you know
it's gonna be a good time yeah we're
doing feedback on all right now no no
brick brick free break it out yeah fire
your gun fire my gun no that didn't work
out oh you really got to do the melee in
that situation he he went in he's also
dead yeah I got though man she's never
getting getting into like bigger bigger
games now - yeah that's good yeah what a
box night good to see you hope you're
having a good day
aarti dirty is now following me damn
just like that dude Wow someone time
someone no it's someone took the name
there I went with it got their own
Twitter account I hear some footsteps
someone's running around I thought I was
just in my head
no sure net that's smart hey that makes
you more aerodynamic oh there's chests
with Oh with all huh that's how he's
good now he's smart so he knows where to
go we got to find armor now armors the
next move yeah hey a moose shark good to
see a fantastic name like both of those
animals don't worry
Dutch has a plan don't don't even don't
even worry about it
true good points point out you wouldn't
shoot him what are you guys doing shoot
each other what huh this looks a little
buggy Ben it does a little bit
ah that was so weird
okay sure yeah she did it I think I
think he did it
oh yeah coop says you've gone Hollywood
now that that dirty already follows you
on twitter yeah I guess so
Megan making a big I gotta kill dan dan
dan dan dan he's not in one person I've
gotta find the money why do we have to
have two of these ending like winning
screens like just get that's the one
they're putting all the extra all the
extra stuff in the wrong places
bring back the standoffs at the
beginning give me just the the thing
where the person's giving the thumbs-up
at the end give them their moment get it
going again mm-hmm
you enjoying this game mode or what dr.
Phil wants to know yeah I'm enjoying it
um when there's people playing it and I
think it's it's it's a little
inconsistent with like the rhythm of it
you know what I mean where you you want
to compare to like any other game like
that's boy Battle Royale like fortnight
or bub jeez it's hard to get it I know
again that that rhythm and pacing of
like okay I like it I don't know like
it's hard to walk away with like what
exactly went wrong so far I guess I'm
trying to say like I'm like I you know
you're trying to get into an either nice
rhythm where you're understanding like
had progressed or how to get like better
I guess yeah that's what that's the
ideal I don't know I'm still I'm still
surprised that we haven't gotten a full
game yet and that's someone just asked
and I forget who
was what the max players isn't it's 32
yeah we still haven't gotten that yet
it's like it's hard to have an opinion
the most we've had is like 20 20 22 yeah
it's almost there
oh that's a guy chased down
oh my god was he coming at me with a
knife I not anymore he's not
that dudes turbo debt thank God his
horse is okay there's two people here I
didn't even seen it I looked over just
in time to see the whole like thing play
out
you just bump into that tent ass Jamie I
do that the back and forth was Ryan guys
were trading shots off at the wrong time
yeah exactly right I should have just
waited I did not get that right come but
that mounted kill was was so much yeah
that was tight Mike my character looks
like a clouded up Clint Eastwood that's
dive yes dive it's always the dive
always got it's gotta go back to the
dive was a horrible shooting let's do it
again one more time do it again I
thought that was someone like shaking
something over there Mike it's just the
music all right so we got people joining
eight people cool cool eight uh what
closes the circle or is it just reefer
also there's a circle that closes as
time goes on but it doesn't seem like it
goes in random places because it's in
such a small area so it's like ah the
map is Fort Mercer but it's gonna close
in on Fort Mercer so there's not really
like strategy for finding different
parts of the map to maybe hide in it
seems it's maybe maybe they just need to
make it bigger you know yeah it's kind
of hard to well the other thing too is
that you can't really the only the only
way you can visually see the circle
closing in is on your mini-map yeah it'd
be cool what they could have done like a
dust storm or something like that you
know yeah what is what would red Dead's
circle be way ahead a tree weather or
something yeah in order for it to be
authentic have it grounded in reality
yeah make it canon yeah I agree
doing this mode with bigger areas would
be I think much better like I don't know
maybe the states is a good suggestion
the first thing my mind was like ah
let's just do all of like all of one
half of the map like yeah I mean that's
a factor of a player count though you
know yeah like you got it you got to
have [ __ ]
oh my god
he had some time to wake up there he's
missing more than you are though so I
think you're all right now SEC Mayo the
hits I don't like this gun yeah that
guns not great step those those early
semi-automatic pistols oh yeah we can
try T mode me that's where everyone is
that's not bad idea
you're good way to mix it up a bit yeah
let's do that after this I do like that
this map always has the sandstorm on it
though it seems
nice ass man
mm-hmm
crap I have no idea where they went crap
here those shots though
risky I'm closed for this I saw someone
oh he's got armor ding it's a guy hiding
in the house I was gonna rush live now
yes it is it is live now ready to go so
you want to try some some team stuff
yeah put the whole team on your back
carry him to victory see just then I go
for the head shot that was the bloom
it's true so you gotta you gotta work up
that Deadeye first it's it's an
interesting battle royale I said I don't
know if it'll it'll take over anyone's
like main one but it's it's nice that
it's kind of there I guess it's cool
cool thing if you feeling like it
currently matchmaking
hmm fortnight is superior this fortnight
it's a different game than this game ah
um spider eggs joined thanks I feel like
there are more people here this might be
the thing playing this and I got a full
Lobby shoot me red - doesn't like us yet
crime brings up a good point sometimes
you just play against the bringing
snake-oil [ __ ] or is it just buying it
for your regular find out a giddyup back
in the saddle when did this come out
just today they they put a small update
out that put a new mode in and they
detail a whole bunch of their upcoming
stuff for Red Dead online kind of giving
everyone a rundown and letting you know
that they're there they're working on it
they're taking feedback they're
adjusting they're moving things yeah
doesn't have much frills cuz everyone's
using auto-aim
yeah I think you can still have an
exciting time with auto-aim
I mean for me with without Auto way in
the exciting time would be both players
shooting 20 shots at each a missing the
hole exactly like if the controls were
tighter than you could maybe get away
with that I thought we had yellow color
the game told you no you're you're
purple now that's your that's your
friend Dan days oh so I can be I could
do oh yeah you can well there you go
partner ding wait up that's okay yeah
yeah get on the horse and just take off
oh great yeah there's a guy right here
idiot sure it is it is beta it's a good
thing to remind people that it's it's a
beta they're working on it I'm excited
for more of the story to come into
whenever they finally get that going
there's no auto-aim in the first Red
Dead there was Otto him in the first Red
Dead it was actually my favorite kind of
auto-aim because it locks onto people's
chests and if you want to get robbed
yeah that works you just bend and heed
my friend uh all that for just that that
one kill worth it just totally worth it
I'm sure good pick up his goddamn there
are two hats down there he's wearing -
oh you think up hats but other guns that
make sense maybe yeah
the dandies give their regards ooh hello
a lot of people dead here oh yeah well I
don't know if it really matters at this
point but you've lost your teammate oh
yeah I figured yeah Oh
hmm stop it oh here he comes here it
comes
dang it what did he just do
I got a warp I did a dive that time you
did and it was it was good oh this guy's
not even here
no he's not he's playing the game should
be called Red Dead Royale it should I
feel like that's that's two two there
though so they had to be different okay
no one wants to be in the low some
Cowboys lonesome cowboy is old campaign
dude I'm a I'm a dandy fiend dad dandy
till the day you die dad that died in
days well that guy looks like Dante from
Devil May Cry that cool white hair yeah
look at that
yeah he he looks threatening that we'll
have to see how he plays giddyup
everyone wants to be on dandies you I
don't blame him you see how he did the
last match yeah killing it yeah that guy
is real lonely it's good looking good
looking group yeah some uh some real our
odds are high Oh
[Laughter]
the lonesome gone out or none left oh oh
it's a glitch red banana just joined
oh cool dude says they're just in our
game so people are finding us somehow
still I like I really like this image
here it's three people on a team who do
not see this plain sight guys left
everyone face one direction and shoot
one guy and that seems about right
it's the online experience ignoring your
surroundings oh yeah Dan days oh you
lost Dante [ __ ] can't believe this
well now we're gonna lose he's gonna
flip and jump out of somewhere and I'll
throw pizza everywhere you're enjoying
uh I don't know only done one match of
it so far but are you enjoying team
stuff more than the regular I feel like
it's quicker it's quicker I don't know I
like in the and the other I've heard of
the other modes in this game I kind of
like this more than the other ones I
guess I wonder like how much to get you
know how much experience and loot you're
taking away but yeah I think you were
telling me like that's the best way to
like get experience right now crap
there's a guy is by playing the
multiplayer stuff the competitive stuff
it's over quick there's guy next to you
okay I think yep there's guys next to
you oh dang it beam up you know what
Robbie got this you knock my oh no it's
doctor
you are the chosen one I shouldn't have
gone for the guy in the horse that's
right Dante saw his opportunity he
seized it he knew it was up if only he
stayed on your team F oh man I want a
battle royale my uh pretend so how do
people drop just meet each other and
talk yeah
I'd be down for that like a friend a
friendly Royale yo I am NOT I'm I'm all
about the dandy this damn you're gonna
team I can't all right what's the next
coyote pack blood money King wizard
bioshock may these people got some names
i am on that team drama there's a story
there there was a some some rising
action some falling action can I change
my hat that seems like just like a
freaking target right no I think you're
locked into your your hats when you're
doing team stuff sick it's like dandies
have got their their hats and oh I got
you it's it's all an aesthetic thing you
know you got to represent who you're
playing as right
great you're not even a dandy your
coyote though nailed it
yeah that's pretty that's pretty good
coyotes alright you feeling it this is
it this is it this is this this yeah
look at that
warm-up jump there okay let's do this
you guys follow me follow my lead I know
what I'm doing
[Music]
get me on the uh has the change in the
controls worked out pretty much
oh I'm just thinking about now I'm not
really well you could hear me mashing it
still it's not the match to sprint
Oh gotcha okay yeah yeah you're
definitely right with the shooting I
think I've noticed that the other thing
that really hurts when I play this game
is the fact that when you're aim it took
me like 30 hours to realize this but
when you actually pull your gun up to
aim you have to tap X while you're
aiming to be able to like jog and move
quicker mm-hmm
otherwise you just stop basically and
that does not help out at all so you've
got to do like L 2 X every time you're
aiming got it keep getting put in the
same match about to make a whole bunch
of really cool friends the deer coyotes
ooh
blood bunnies on it got a little Russ
get their hats
wahoo tag them back
move Bioshock no dang
I was I was really worried about that
one I'm not gonna lie
yeah cuz I just had a pistol in that
scenario there yeah I got a bolt-action
rifle though so that's pretty good
only five shots though find something
else
pistol yeah stick with what you know
you're it's not treating you too bad
that's good as her team deathmatch in
Red Dead - yes see he didn't even Auto
him now on though he was aiming it
before the guy popped out both both of
those were manual yeah I mean auto aim
is definitely on but those shots were
not auto shots oh dang blood bunny did
he shoot that guy over there was that he
was shot thank you can only tell there's
only one person left you see the movie
oh oh just get a dirty arty soundboard
to play over your microphone seriously
get this fear he's gonna come up right
behind me is this mode free for all
owners as long as you have access to the
online beta you should be able to play
it carefulness 100% feeling it
how are the micro transactions in this
game kind of weird you got to pay money
for a duster coat but you also can earn
premium currency if you're playing but
it only gives you two in like hundredths
of parts so it's it takes a while
is there any cover-up here kinda where's
this guy well you guys are good you just
hanging out in Fort Mercer so just gonna
wait for him to show up just Gary how do
they drop so you don't you don't drop
per se you just care to go I nailed it
that's that's two in the bag today
killing it so you don't drop you just
kind of all start out at the outside of
the map and you have to run in it's it's
not a hundred percent better al but it's
got better royale
it's got battle royale blood in it
there's a lot of picking up weapons in
trying to not by the closing circle
that's a real good look for him I like
that MVP I'm gonna get that make sure
I'll take it heck yeah eight dollars for
all of that work just Shh well I like
this coyote pack there's a good coyotes
ya know if the characters reset with
multiplayer launches I have no idea it's
easier to get hit in the head when you
Crouch walk it's true because I think
when you do auto-lock it kind of just
goes right towards there yeah the the
auto run when Crouch is good did switch
to that
[Music]
team is better I agree
literally LED and gold letting gold was
an interesting idea and I kind of kind
of wish it it did better but yeah it had
issues looks pretty okay yeah the more
I'm watching it the more I'm kind of
like this isn't too bad it's just an
extra thing to like it's just one of
like five game modes I hope they bring
back the coop that was kind of cool
co-op and slow and I didn't play didn't
play much red that online at all so one
of their updates the kids the original
red that online put out like a series of
four player co-op missions where you I
remember like one of them you like start
off and you got to take these
stagecoaches and deliver like military
equipment to a place to set up a defense
mmm against something but they're
they're like actual story missions but
in their own storyline kind of like our
story stuff we have now but yeah I want
I want more of that I want more of the
story
give me more story to play the co-op
missions on hard were very hard
wait up like I broke off
I wish you could play red dead right now
but my xbox isn't working that's no good
sorry to hear that is there a date for
multiplayer launch yet not yet but they
say it's gonna be in beta for a few more
months so hopefully not too long can you
Rob oh yeah you can't rob banks yet I'm
really excited for whenever that happens
dude you can't even really rob banks
there's guys over there can't even
really robbed banks in the single-player
though you know I can't even rob stores
in single-player I think you can rob
store oh don't Sinclair yeah yeah
single-player I'm still thinking
multiplayer right oh right yeah you're
right but uh yeah there are there are
only specific missions for robbing banks
maybe that's how it'll work in
multiplayer too yeah like at level 25
you get your first opportunity to rob a
bank oh [ __ ] oh god that sounds very
unpleasant that sounds fun oh this is
two teams is just two teams yeah there's
it's the dandies in the coyotes you know
- you're lying I can't believe this my
old gang [ __ ] let's go
switch
huh what's going on I can't go out of
here
why the way oh he's around here ya know
so you just taking a nap oh that that
looks real thunderstorms on it
Oh what on - got it know how that even
happened he willed that into existence
he shot him with his mind uh they should
allow posses and crews like in Max Payne
3 I think they've got posses and I think
they have crews as well but it's not all
fully implemented yet are the pending on
adding more co-op missions to
multiplayer there's gonna be another
story chapter coming up from what you
were saying in the roadmap so maybe
we'll get that soon what happened his
character got got got got jumps 11
people in this the Dan days hi guys
there you go Hey alright we do one more
yeah I'm down okay sounds like a plan
do one more see how it goes and then
just a reminder later on today John Luke
and I are gonna be back playing the
Resident Evil 2 demo to play throughs to
co-hosts 2 p.m. Pacific don't miss it to
be where you're in for a scare
all that would be a good time off the
scale
there was one guy on one one of those
teams not really a team he's he's
feeling spicy he's ready to to just drop
in and take on the world
no loot other players it's not better al
then you can loot people but I don't
know if you can get like their weapons
off of them maybe that's how it works
cuz they don't actually drop their guns
maybe you have to like but I think I did
that one guy yeah I did I totally did
loot him yeah that's what I was figuring
but alright oh wait that's not that Dan
days and you're by yourself the whole
again full again f so our last team game
isn't really a team game it's definitely
gonna be in third period there's only
one team that has two people on it sick
Hey look at it this way your team color
gives you the best advantage camouflage
wise you're goddamn right your hat may
look silly but you're gonna be real hard
to spot nice cous bumps reference aim
the police
perfect creepy time a double-action
revolvers a good pickup so many scarves
true they love their skin more dirty
arty it's gonna be happening tomorrow
it's buck buckle up oh there should be
she talked to rock star and get it and
put the dirty Artie's in as a gang be so
cool
oh shoot yeah the original gross treat
got some gross Street colors going on
that hat looks so flat sit whoo that's a
that's a statement Oh
battle royale with like uncharted
controls would be great I always really
liked uncharted 2 multiplayer because of
how vertical it is it's very very good
I felt that explosion are you are you
tapping into the game right now yeah so
this is a free-for-all right now there
there are no teams well I thought you
say there's one team with two one of the
people got taken out here now it's
free-for-all now it's a free-for-all
so free-for-all with team colors
I thought I was coming up behind someone
but you died or he fled
I feel like I shouldn't talk so much
from trying to no you're fine
I'll let you like focus here oh [ __ ]
I want a better shot some pretty distant
shots happening perfect nail it nailed
it just don't like off almost off the
ledge she sees me oh my boy there goes
my hat goodness I can't do one more that
was a horrible horrible
it was your old teammate blood-money f
that's why I couldn't do it
I'm neon dolphin for 20 it's a heck of a
name look I should just kill them that's
horrible
alright you got excited about the double
action revolver I get excited about the
double action revolver it's a good time
yeah you already already twice a week
sorry okay off oh I wasn't saying you
want to do one more for sure yeah I'm
gonna do one more okay I can't go out
like that one more it is not like these
yeah someone's calling out the dope the
double dirty arty there's no way those
take those take a week to produce
stretch if there if there were a way to
bring more dirty arty to the people I'm
sure that that Robin Jake would do it
what I'm kind of upset that I think they
took the Wilhelm scream out from the
deaths why not more dirty it's it takes
a lot of work and we have a lot of other
things going on here unfortunately it's
true
poverty we're taking now a little bit
longer with dirty already in the and
that we used to be record for an hour
and then like the last two have been
like two hours oh really yeah
it's crafting a fine now a fine story
yeah he's saying that everyone stinks
it's like get out of here yeah you're
you're crafting a storyline an intricate
detailed storyline with characters and
and in places and thoughts it's it takes
time you've got you've got some real
cash money going on I know I noticed
that yeah I don't know how that happened
32 gold bars you know how many how many
duster coach you could buy with that ma
3200 they are just one gold bar I think
they're just one gold bar mmm one more
job before Tahiti
one more Arthur who the hell is dirty
Artie if you don't know there is a
series that Rob and Jacob Decker to
where to take the grossest dirtiest
cowboy on the wildest of journeys it's a
weekly series you should check it out
it's a whole playlist for it there's a
new one coming out tomorrow so be a good
time to kind of check it out and see
what's going on but you should
definitely watch all of them though a
lot of people want people were that
dirty Artie people like it like it
we're on episode chapter sorry I keep
saying episode bits calling them chapter
10 is tomorrow so stay tuned double
digits the Boot Hill Gang what a
horrible name it's like that like the
Sugar Hill Gang
but without without rapping
I'll have you played the game on yet
we're playing it right now we just
started up this this match we're
drinking all of our drinks we're getting
ready to go
it's the the last one of the day howdy
here in the woods start off with a
hunting knife that's not too bad I
thought that was a person but it's
actually just horse only two teams with
two people on them too if you see a
purple or green look for a second yeah
keep keep an eye on them perfect perfect
perfect nailed it
stuck the landings is good footage nope
it took a little while for him to
realize that he got killed who would
want to pick up his body it says pick up
the hottie you want to send a message
man I don't know yeah okay hold your boy
I got him it's right here is the solar
team so this mode is teams but there
aren't enough people to have all teams
so if you can see at the top there are
two teams with two and two teams with
three teams with one including us
did they fix people getting kicked yet
we haven't gotten kicked out yet it
might be a lot better now thinking they
might have done a good job with that
odo terrain my natural enemy you know
where we're coming from
Oh God
it was the two-person team you would
have been fine it was the daddies it's
always the dandy whew all right whatever
has cool whatever yeah yeah if you look
good feeling feel excited no no no we
didn't get armor once we need armor
armors a crutch okay looks like a
jackass yeah it does look at him scoot
around all right
well oh that's if you have the body over
your shoulder it would look like a human
work like a human shield that's not a
bad idea what if that was interesting
yeah you would move very slowly he'll
these are the the tactics that you can
try out in Red Dead online these twos
new mode that's right get your battle
royale on it's time to survive it sure
is but not for us it's actually more of
a time for us to probably go and try to
get like a like a like a lunch or a
snack or something at that's annoying
yeah you ready close it out I am ready
closing out thank you guys so much for
watching and checking out this new mode
yeah rush a wonderful time so it's
always good to be hanging out with you
Rob here yeah yeah check out all the
stuff Christopher I wrote up all the
things that they're doing the road map
it's really cool changing things read it
online it's changing let's get out of
here 2:00 p.m. today she's an evil
Resident Evil's Emma run through Sean
Luca night don't be a fool stay in
school play Jacques play dog and Rob I'm
hitting the outro button good bye